we've always had this idea that we could
have an artificial being that would
resemble a human being it was the
conceptual idea that we need to program
computers that can make decisions like a
human would make decisions this
interview is with Kenneth kukier now
Kenneth is a journalist a writer and the
deputy executive editor for The
Economist he's written the phenomenally
bestselling book big data which is sold
over 2 million copies which is all about
the role of big data in the world and he
was actually one of the people who kind
of popularized the term back in like
2010 and his latest book framers looks
at the ways in which humans are able to
uniquely reason and understand things in
a way that AI can't gbt is not giving
you the answer remember it's an
inference gbt is giving you what it
thinks a correct answer looks like in
this conversation we talk about the idea
of big data and then we talk about
artificial intelligence and how the
field developed over the last like 70
years we talk about some of the risks
that we actually face from Ai and what
we can do about it like what sort of
world we want to live in and how we can
use AI as almost a co-pilot for various
different things rather than relying on
it as being like the sole Arbiter for
truth absolutely it's going to take our
jobs not everyone's job I think there's
always going to be work to do whether
that's well-paid work whether that's
satisfying work is up to us to create
work is definitely going to change
everyone's work is going to change but
that's happened with electricity that
happened with computers we need to
reimagine what will bring value to the
world and then do that by the way in
case you haven't heard the book that
I've been working on for the last 3
years is now available for order it is
called Feelgood productivity and it's
available on Amazon and all other major
retailers and you can check out the
website Feelgood productivity.com for
more information and links to where you
can get yourself a copy all right Ken
welcome to the show um to start with I'd
love to hear a little bit about your
background and how you ended up getting
interested and involved in Ai and these
sort of Big Data topics that you talk
about what a good topic what what a
great place to begin and thank you for
having me on the show so I actually sort
of remember the moment where I had a
little Epiphany a little aha which was
uh in Cambridge Massachusetts uh walking
down the street and realizing that all
of the world could be rendered as
information that you could put on a lens
if you will sort of glasses and then see
absolutely everything through a
different way of seeing it law a lawyer
would see absolutely an architect would
see everything every right angle and
would see every plane a lawyer would see
every product liability and would see
every opportunity every tort to sue but
a physicist or maybe even just a
inquisitive person in the beginning at
the outset this was the around the year
2002 of the Information Society could
look at it and sort of render absolutely
everything in a datafied format as
information okay uh you would look at
every building and see the height of it
you'd feel the wind and understand that
there'd be temperature and a wind speed
and a direction to that wind you
understand that you have a pulse in
therefore for it could be measured as a
heartbeat and hemoglobin levels and
blood you know sugar levels it's all
very peculiar to think that you would be
able to measure absolutely everything in
the world but this is an Insight that I
then realized um many people have had
for centuries before whether it's Isaac
asanov and science fiction like
Foundation whether it was um uh Klay who
I forgot now his first name I think it
was ysf Klay no alons Klay who was a uh
Belgian uh sort of physiocrat physician
stroke sociologist
who then created this idea of the Len
the the average man and wrote what he
called the social physics which was this
the physique social was the idea of
enumerating absolutely everything in
order to understand it so um and there
was even what uh gaun and haly in in
Britain in the 1600s who were able to
take look at astronomy and realize that
you could measure the night sky but then
during daylight would look at
contemporary Britain and realize you can
identify how many people are going to
die in a given year you don't know who
you don't know where you don't know when
but you can get a rough estimation with
a known or margin of error of the annual
deaths of a population and you could
then also sell insurance based on that
right you could understand that number
of fires in London for example the
origin of insurance was just that
enumerating things so I was struck by
that Epiphany and realized that in the
Information Society as we did more of
our activities intered intermediated
with a computer online in digital format
we as a default collected information it
was just a byproduct and we could
suddenly start using that
information I took that Insight like so
many of us do I took that Insight socked
it away never thought about it again
forgot about it for like a decade and
then lo and behold one day I was the
Tokyo correspondent of The Economist and
the call went out for cover Story cover
ideas and with this glorious like
15-page spread that correspondents get
to do and an quasi
unlimited uh expense budget this was
before the financial crisis and I
realized this is the moment to do a
story on the information of the
Information Society collecting
information I'd heard of AI but at the
time no one believed it worked it was
sort of poo pooed in the Academy I had
heard of machine learning had no idea
really what it meant but I plowed into
this around the year 2009 so it's early
and at the very end of my searches and
blowing a lot of money for The Economist
I basically had nothing and crying into
my soup in Silicon Valley one day at San
Francisco the night before I left with a
friend he interrupts me and he says you
know what I do don't I don't you and I
said yeah you're some sort of Internet
entrepreneur he's like I have a big data
company I said big data what's that
therein began a series of introductions
uh cover story The Economist in the fall
EX in February of 2010 on Big Data
introducing the term to uh the sort of
Main stream audience oh really is that
how the term going oh right it was I did
not coin the term yeah but um but the
media the General Media traditional
media hadn't been reporting on it and I
think one of the earliest in instances
of the term big data used to describe
machine learning as a shorthand but also
this idea that the amount of information
had grown to such a degree that we
needed to use new techniques and new
infrastructure to process it if you will
there's a there there Big Data actually
means something specific
because it had to describe something
that was going on beforehand under a
different set of constraints and
different set of mechanisms and
processes and people and talents this
new uh technique of Big Data it was sort
of inaugurated in that in 2010 on the
pages of The Economist in a cover story
and the reception to that was so
enormous that from that moment on I
realized I'm in the data business damn
yeah cuz I I remember I like I think I
first came across the term in like 20 I
want to say 2011 2012 sure this was when
I was getting into medical school and
you know researching like what could
they ask me at interview and at the time
there was a little bit of a sort of
Rumblings in the medical world around
sort of this idea of big data and how it
applies to like patient data and like
enormous blood test results that we have
going back like decades and how to get
insights from that and cuz I was sort of
interested in technology I was like oh
maybe this could be an angle that I kind
of talk about thankfully they never ask
me any questions about it cuz I really
wasn't prepared but well do so bad you
got in anyway but um but the but it was
around that time it was around 2011 I
was writing the book big data 2012 it
came out so it's about a decade old it's
still not there which is sort of
interesting the the the intellectual
underpinnings of using data in society
to improve Society is sort of understood
but to actually make social change takes
a long time takes decades in the case of
medicine we're still not using
information I mean we use it in a
pointless way like a an internist will
walk walk by the the bedside of a person
in the hospital would pick up a
clipboard or the digital equivalent of
it um and will look at the at the
numbers and make a decision on it and
that's ridiculous and obscene because
really what you want to do is to have
every single person who's had that exact
same condition and meets the same
criteria of the patient going back a
decade and you would then have a sort of
a co-pilot if you will as the term that
we now use in terms of using AI to
support human beings
would to then make its own estimation
and you might want to Blind the two and
see if the two decisions in terms of the
next therapy next you know diagnostic uh
is the same in which you're confirming
it or then to if you have a difference
add a third person a Minority Report if
you will a third person to make a
decision on it to vote in One Direction
or the other and then to use the
feedback of what happened was it the
right diagnostic or not and of course
it's never white or black so you so it's
it's a it's a spectrum of rsh or
wrongish what what are the Alternatives
you don't know the counterfactual and
then to feed that back in to the next
person Google does this for search so if
you if everyone starts clicking on the
second search result for the same search
term or better yet if everyone's
clicking on the eighth search result for
a given search term Google the algorithm
knows to move it up to the first or
second place because it's clearly the
most popular each click is a vote so why
don't we do that in healthcare it's
crazy and again it's obscene because all
it takes is the will and a bit of do and
we improve patient outcomes and we
improve society and we lower our
costs yeah yeah I think there's there's
so much here where um like whenever
anyone I know for me as well whenever we
start working in medicine and we see the
amount of data that is available and
then see the fact that it's all you know
in the UK some of it is still in pen and
paper system some of it you have to use
four different apps to access like your
blood tests and then the sort of the
vital signs of the patient and another
one for your scans and another one for
the drug stuff and it's like there are
very few systems that integrate all the
things and the ones that do like I I was
working in Cambridge Aden Brooks
hospital that did integrate all the
things and it was incredible I could run
my whole night shift from like the cafe
Burger King downstairs cuz they always
have Burger Kings in hospital for some
reason and just like on the iPad because
they it had an iPad app was you know
someone ring me about a patient I'd be
able to immediately see all the things
it still wasn't co-pilot and that it
wasn't telling me what to do next but
even just the basics of just having all
the information in one place was pretty
good starting point um yeah well we
might not for keep in mind we might not
want it to be a full co-pilot system
particularly for you at the outset of
your career we wanted you to make
decisions in fact we sort of sadly want
you to make mistakes because if you make
mistakes when you're young you probably
won't when you're old what we would like
to do is maybe validate your decision or
have you reconsider your decision right
so if the you know if the if you think
that this person has gallstones and in
fact it turns out it's septus right and
anyone could see it a mile away and your
supervisor would but it's 4 in the
morning right we want the AI system and
or in this case the Big Data System to
Simply prod you and say have you
considered septus right and and we just
say ah yeah maybe maybe that's right and
you can reconsider um it might want to
tell you its confidence its its degree
of confidence in its diagnosis in which
it says that actually we think it's
different but it's really only with a
60% likelihood or degree of confidence
in this instance where you're quite sure
that it's actually not this for this
other intervening reason uh the toxicity
of the patient would kill him if you
were to give that particular drug for
example um those are the ways in which
we would use data effectively but it
requires two things one probably a
regulatory change we need to sort of
loosen privacy rules in certain wise
ways that are still governed under very
strict law but loosened for this social
goal uh Privacy Law never presumed a
world of statistics and presumed
commercial rapaciousness it didn't
really it doesn't really accept the idea
that with a large body the big
data message which is or if you will
lead Motif with a large body of data you
can do things that you inherently can't
do with a smaller amount of it it's not
about the point list sliver of
information but the a glomeration of
large body of data asking new questions
answering them in more um deeper and
more accurate ways than we ever could
and granular ways than we ever could
imagine that's the first the bigger
problem is a is a change of mindset we
need if you will a data duty of care
mindset and that is to
say we can't accept a world in which um
we're going to make human decisions and
we're going to try to validate those
decisions with a smidgen of information
that confirms what we think we're
looking at we we reframe it we inverse
the reverse the process if you will and
say that it's not a nice to have it's a
thou must have you have a legal and
moral responsibility to apply data to
questions that we can use the data to
help us answer and if you don't you're
negligent and on the hawk so it's not
like a doctor says um here's my decision
and here's how I Justified it with the
data but it says this here's my decision
and if I didn't use data to confirm it
and to validate it
I have not performed my duty of care to
my patient and I go to jail or I'm I'm
on for on the hawk for liability if we
had a world like that you would never
have an environment in which patients go
in and hope the best for whoever is
making a blur ey decision at 4 in the
morning because you're always going to
have this sort of support mechanism of
every single data point the NHS has
collected over the last decade for every
patient that looks like
mine that would be great if if we could
move to that World um so the book Big
Data what like I mean it's it's sold
like 2 million copies now it's like
absurdly large number for like that's
insanely successful for a non-fiction
book for people who might be listening
who are not familiar with like sales
numbers for things uh I'm looking a lot
at sales numbers now cuz I'm like oh
like you know when you're in that
world you realize what that like for a
book to sell 2 million copies that's
like absolutely phenomenal um so that
aside like what is the book big data
about so the book Big Data uh we have to
remember it I think a lot I always knew
when I was writing it that within about
10 or 15 20 years it success would be
such that no one would understand what
we were talking about at that future
date because I wouldn't really believe
that the world could have been such a
medieval place that people didn't use
data based on what they're doing I mean
classic example is marketing like all of
marketing now applies information to it
when you send an email who you send it
how you segment it right um in the past
we used to have segment ations of of
potential customers but Amazon came in
and let's think about the segments that
the Amazon homepage uses right do they
segmented by country do they segmented
by male female does the homepage of
amazon.com segment the consumer by time
of day or the IP address whether it's
the central business district or a
residential district no these questions
are Preposterous there is no Amazon
homepage there's if there's if there's
1.5 billion Amazon customers there's 1.5
different homepages yeah now think about
the you know the the app of the New York
Times for The
Economist that's still segmented right
that and in fact that's probably just
done on a a geography based with a
little bit of of items that are
recommended based on previous you know
consumption behaviors right so there's a
ways to go the book Big Data was taking
that original Insight that all of the
world can be sort of seen through the
lens of information and if we could
collect information and process it
wisely emphasize the word wisely we can
solve a lot of problems that we couldn't
before because we'll be asking different
questions while having better answers
I.E more accurate answers and more
granular answers to the problems that we
face and that we have a moral duty to
apply information to our problems to use
human data being empirical evidence of
the world in order to improve the world
and it it was in response to a world in
which we weren't doing any of those
things in most
domains underneath that is the concept
that
the that as I said before there are
things you can do with a large body of
information that you fundamentally
cannot do with a smaller amount of it
that the change in scale leads to a
change in state or that the quantitative
shift leads to a qualitative shift that
more isn't just more that more is
different
what's a a practical example of this to
just to make it more Concrete in in
people's minds sure so I mean um let's
maybe think first in Search and then go
right into into medicine so if you
wanted to understand the way that spam
filters would work I mean for your
younger audiences I should probably
explain what spam is sit down my
children you know at the outset of the
internet emails were free keep in mind
before then post you know postcards were
expensive letters were expensive and
calls were charged by the minute uh this
is about 25 years ago so it's within
your some of your some of their
memories so email was free and as a
result spam used to clutter up our
inboxes of course we still get that
today but we never even see it and the
reason why is our spam filters are so
incredibly effective and the reason why
is we no longer have spam filters based
on human beings making decisions on
whether a given piece of item is Spam or
not but we have machines do it and how
they do it is through machine learning
what we do is we have uh an algorithm
that looks at the known traits of spam
but then has has to start from somewhere
right Viagra extensions of one's you
know of one's um bodily Parts but then
what it does is it accepts in a in a
basy and statistic way it's making an
inference with a lot of blurriness on
the sides to say that maybe Viagra isn't
spelled v i a g r a but the Roman Roman
numeral one or actually Arabic numeral
one the a might be four G R4 every human
will read it as Viagra now how would you
know that that would be like how would
you design a system that that and a
program for a computer to follow a set
of instructions to say that that is
Viagra and the answer is that you really
wouldn't like it'd be hard to get every
single you know permutation of how to
misspell Viagra that would be
understandable to a human but a machine
wouldn't be able to find out in the hard
and fast code so instead you use machine
learning to make an inference and when
you see a lot of these things coming
through you then scored and you see one
or two people maybe put into their Spam
folders on Gmail suddenly you do that
across the board and you stop hundreds
of millions of items of spam coming
through and that's what happens so we
have a machine learning algorithm making
inferences take that exact same approach
where you don't know the answer but you
design a system that's going to make an
inference based on a large of data and
if you don't have a large body of data
you can't do this with a small body of
data you wouldn't have enough
information and you're going to say spot
The Telltale traits of cancer years
before the cancer actually forms so it's
not yet cancer but it's the cells that
are growing in such a way that it's
probably going to become cancerous again
you need a large body of data and when
you have that you then you train on the
data that you know and then you look at
things that you don't know and you then
make a prediction that's the big data
story so you take that same approach and
actually the same Engineers who worked
on a spam filter at Google will publish
a paper on how to read an I scan a
retina scan and identify who's going to
develop cancer and this now this is
actually now um relatively simple I mean
there has been now 10 years of academic
papers on spotting you know on
diagnosing medical problems based on
large bodies information often
information that's not related to
Medicine itself but is a proxy for the
condition that people are feeling so he
was saying that figuring out where the
AI co-pilot fits into the clinical
workflow is the hard part because then
now all of a sudden you have all of like
the the human issues of like okay cool
is it you know are we using this uh kind
of um are we using the model to
categorize the backlog of tens of
thousands of chest x-rays that we have
okay if that's the case does it need to
then be vetted by second opinion human
okay if not then like are we like how
sensitive or specific is the thing going
to be and in theory yes a data a model
could identify I don't know the fact
that you've got consolidation on a chest
x-ray or whatever but like what does
that practically mean for the healthcare
system is the thing that we've not yet
figured out I know and and these are
great problems to have I mean we're
frankly blessed that we can actually
even think through these problems so
let's get started let's figure out well
what should workflow look like what does
the consumer expect what does the
consumer expect under what conditions so
for example I for if it's cancer and
it's you know lung cancer where the you
know getting an accurate uh diagnostic
is uh is very essential but it doesn't
take particularly too long and a delay
of a day of 24 hours isn't going to mean
life or death then you know then that's
going to change the workflow and the
processes in which we apply it but if
we're trying to understand um whether we
need to operate on a person's brain
because there's a hemorrhage going on
inside the skull and we can get an
inaccurate diagnosis and we know how
it's going to be we we can quantify the
degree of inaccuracy let's say it's
going to be 15 or 20% one in five it's
going to be misdiagnosed in either
direction but we get an answer in 4
seconds and not 40 minutes I.E we're
saving 50% of people's lives let's go
with her I mean that that's that's a
no-brainer in an emergency situation and
what about if it's not at a large
Metropolitan Hospital in London in which
you get a World's foremost expert
looking at it but it's somewhere in the
hinderland in Niger they would rather
have you know an a any diagnosis then no
diagnosis at all right um and that's
just for a today issue because of course
as this becomes democratized these tools
uh their standards are going to increase
and their talents are going to increase
and suddenly I can I can imagine a day
in which some person you know in a deep
dark place in the world needs an needs
has an appendix operation and it needs
to go and go out now to save the life of
the person and you're going to see
something that looks like a um uh one of
those uh uh cargo uh containers right
being transported by helicopter and
either dropped down maybe by parachuting
down because it's made of aluminum and
it's light and out's going to become a
uh a totally sterile surgical robot
that's going to PR first and surgical
doctor if you will medical doctor first
performing confirming the diagnosis that
this is indeed what's required and then
inside a plastic tent uh in totally
sterile conditions operating on the
person and saving the person's life is
that going to happen my own lifetime I'm
a healthy lad let's find out but let's
get started let's have these
conversations right now nice um so one
of the stuff one of the things that you
you've been researching a lot more
recently is artifici artificial
intelligence um and I wonder
for people who are listening to this
like let's imagine someone like
everyone's heard of AI at this point
we've heard of we've all heard of chat
GPT
um but I think going a level deeper in
understanding like what is it like how
did it get like how did it develop over
time and why is it that some people have
been talking about AI for like 10 plus
years others have just heard about it
last year when Chad GPT got big so I
wonder is like can we start with what is
artificial intelligence like how should
we let's start at the beginning sure uh
even in in in Aristotle and others there
were in the in the Greek mythology there
were
uh examples of uh the idea of the of the
robot human that plays the liar and
tills the fields right so this is
there's always been this beautiful
anthropomorphizing and quest for the the
other which could either be the the
mechanical human that alleviates our
toil and in fact the term robot comes
from Roboto which I think means toil in
cck you can check me and I believe it
was uh come on who who who it was rur
rostrums Universal robots a play by
Carl capit is his name uh from about
1920 all of your right now all of your
listeners are pausing and and going on
Google to find me out I'm a fraud okay
but I'm close enough um and so uh or
also the idea of the Golem or the
Frankenstein monster we not only
anthropomorphize but we create our evils
and embed it in it as well so we've
always had this um idea that we could
have an artificial being that would
resemble a human being but it was Alan
Turing who sort of gave us our initial
construction of it first on paper on
computable numbers identifying that
there could be a universal Computing
machine which would which I fully don't
understand and it would take too long to
truly to explain but and that was around
1935 or so and then around 19 I want to
say about 1950 he writes uh the paper in
the psychology Journal interesting that
mind uh on the imitation game in which
he talks about this introduces the
Turing test later to be called the
Turing test there it was the conceptual
idea that we need to program computers
that can make decisions like a human
would make decisions so suddenly it
pursu it asked the question how do
humans make decisions and so there was a
whole movement around from the 1950s to
the 1990s to take the ways that human
makes humans make decisions and enshrine
that into computers that's through the
hardware and more importantly through
the software and the hardware is pretty
simple in fact we use our computer
hardware analogous to the human mind in
which we have a we have memory and we
have a processor right something that
stores information and something that
uses information to come up with an
input and then an output and an answer
and and the original computers were made
made on the model of the human mind okay
but then we also had to create a system
in which we were going to render into
software the ways in which humans made
decisions so we think sequentially and
we think rationally so if we create a
long list and the original programming
language of AI was called lisp for list
programming we could simply write down
all the rules that we use as heuristics
in terms of making decisions to get our
output that seemed logical it was deeply
deeply flawed and the reason why is
humans don't think sequentially like we
we're a jumble of ideas all at once we
do we think rationally well we've spent
the last 25 years in cognitive
Psychology and Neuroscience to look at
all the ways that we don't think
rationally that we actually embed
cognitive biases through everything that
we do so that that was actually that
showed promise and it got us so far but
no further the early gains became like
fools gold we thought we were getting
closer and closer but then it became
harder and harder and harder to wreak
out any benefit of it so what happened
during this period and then we had these
ideas called the AI winter this was in
the 70s 80s and then later in the 90s
there was one two or three depending on
how you count these but the the broader
point is that these Winters were When
government funding and Industry funding
shriveled up for AI and right about the
year 2000 2005 if you said you worked on
AI
in Academia you got laughed at and
couldn't get a tenure and couldn't get a
post because it just seemed like again
it was a Fool's
Quest Sor right question on this front
yeah so a computer working out that 2
plus 2 equals 4 that's not AI great
question let's let's let's pause the the
the my my discourse to say I'm going to
introduce this concept of machine
learning and Stat what's really a Shand
for statistical machine learning and
changing the method to go into that nice
so 2 + 2al four is um is a truth it's
almost like a almost like a ukian sort
of um uh Foundation right it's it's
basic arithmetic of the the origin of
mathematics um we should also say
mathematics is a little bit trickier
still because at the outset it didn't it
took took several centuries before we
have Millennia before we had the concept
of zero right so we started with one
right we needed a zero and Discovery was
important but that's simply to say that
we needed imagination and and a
conceptual shift to understand
mathematics but we have a one and we
have a two okay we have a 2 plus 2al 4
if we can in if we can enshrine that
into a computer that can generate that
same answer all the time and then can
actually conceptually have an idea that
anything with one added to it becomes
one more sequential that would be AI
right it's it by definition it's it's
intelligent or however we want to Define
intelligence we could talk forever about
it and it's artificial the the key thing
the sort of the one of the earliest
aphorisms in AI was that we call AI
anything we cannot do once we know how
to do it we call it a calculator or we
call it a uh a search engine or we call
it voice recognition or we call it
self-driving cars but the frontier of
what we can't do we refer to as Ai and
then when we have it it's like oh that
that oh that oh that's just a search
engine yeah oh that's nothing like
that's simple used to that right but of
course it's you know Google itself is
absolutely remarkable the reason why is
the explicit versus the implicit a world
in which we're trying to design and the
world of lisp and AI proper the original
of the origin of AI by when the coin was
termed in 1955 at a conference at
Dartmouth by Marvin Minsky and John
McCarthy among others there was about
three people from Britain there one of
them part of the selfes family by the
waye
that there it was about explicitly
instructing a computer a set of
instructions to program it on if I give
you a big uh decision tree if I give you
these instructions to do this you
therefore produce this output and I've
got full explainability I can see on a
piece of paper the program that I've
then introduced into the computer okay
the shift that happened
um weirdly enough around that time in
the late 40s early 50s there was several
people Frank rosenblat is is one of them
who died prematurely a several years
later in his 30s uh they looked at a
different technique and that was to
apply statistics to the problem collect
the data have the machine make an
inference modeled on the human mind on
the neural network of the human mind
with nodes and and a decision layer
sounds a little bit like deep learning
so what happened is that the the the
Grandes of AI it's like an academic
squabble in this case Marvin Minsky and
John McCarthy at MIT and then later at
Berkeley looked at this issue and said
oh that's never going to work and they
were not wrong they were right it wasn't
going to work because of the constraints
in computer processing power and memory
and cost at the time but everyone went
through the the instruction based of AI
classical what was called GOI good
oldfashioned AI GOI and they they
try to embed the a large decision-making
Tree on how to make decisions expert
system is another term for it at the
same time this weird method that was poo
pooed and no one had any trust in around
the 80s and the 90s and the year 2000s
was a statistical machine learning just
give the machine a lot of data let it
work out the system for itself and make
an inference you don't need to know all
of the ways in which it can find these
variables and co-variables and
coefficients to identify why it makes a
decision under these conditions in fact
it's so intricate that it would exceed
our human capacity to grock how to do
that but the effect is that it works and
it works better than alternative systems
take images if I show it lots of IM if I
describe a cat as having hair having
ears having a tail having almond shaped
eyes and whiskers that's great what if
I'm looking at the cat that doesn't have
a tail from behind how do I know it's a
cat right the I'd have to program and
say oh here's the exception what if it's
like this like that right it's crazy to
come You' never the real world is such
you'd never have enough ability to
create all these these exceptions give
it you know a quarter of a trillion
wouldn't be that many but several
million examples of cats under all
lightings all conditions all kind of
cats ask if it's a cat or not it can do
it it's statistical right that method
was totally you know not part of the
research adust agenda but it showed
promise and it was so effective there
was really only three people in the
world who were the leading lights and
their students who were pursuing this
sort of ridiculous ambition one's named
Jeffrey Hinton the other one's named
Yoshi Benjo the third is named yan laon
yan Lon became the head of AI at
Facebook Hinton at Google Yoshi Benjo
stayed uh in Montreal uh in Academia but
became an adviser to companies they won
the touring award a couple years ago
the term deep learning and the AI
revolution of around
2012 was and this was Grace of them
there was other people Peter norvig and
Russell Stewart and uh Stuart Russell
and others the key is this they reframed
AI from trying to give it explicit rules
to giving it information and the the
computer coming up with its own set of
rules through an inference it wasn't
explicit it was now implicit what we
still call it AI just because we don't
have a better term for it but it's a
totally totally different technique and
it's been so successful because of the
cost of memory shot down the amount of
data that we can collect in society
became enormous and the processing power
could be super fast in particular
because of nvidia's chips that use a
sort of Matrix algebra rather than doing
a regular form of mathematical
computation on a CPU they're using a
graphical user inter face so the whole
chip design changed you change all of
these different constraints and suddenly
around 2012 image net showed which was a
which was a competition on identifying
images could could almost you know do as
well as human beings and pretty soon
after it was able to exceed the ability
of human beings to recognize the content
inside of an image whether if it's a
muffin or if it's a puppy uh and whether
it's a school bus with a with a pink
unicorn horn on it this episode is very
excitingly brought to you by hu I've
been a paying customer of hu since 2017
since my 5ifth year of medical school
and it's absolutely fantastic for those
occasions when you need a meal but you
don't have the time to necessarily cook
for yourself now these are some of my
favorite product that hu offers this is
the ready to drink which is a meal in a
bottle and each meal is 400 calories
with 22 g of protein which is pretty
reasonable and each serving has 26
vitamins and minerals as well heal ready
to drink is made from natural
ingredients like tapioca sunflower seed
Co coconut pee protein flax seed and hem
seed protein it is 100% vegan like all
heu meals and it's gluten-free and
lactose free with no animal products and
no GMOs and heu ready to drink comes in
eight different flavors including
strawberries and cream and iced coffee
caramel along with the classics like
chocolate and vanilla now these are
widely available in supermarkets and
Corner shops and petrol stations all
around the UK but the best way to get
them is online and so if you're like me
and you have a fairly busy life where
you don't necessarily have time to cook
or make the time to cook then you might
like to try out hu ready to drink also
if you haven't yet heard the episode EP
of Deep dive with the founder of heel
Julian Hearn you might like to check
that out but if you'd like to give heel
a try then head over to heel.com
deepdive and that link is available in
the video description and the show notes
as well and that link firstly helps me
out but it will also give you a free
t-shirt and a Shaker and so you can
check out heel ready to drink and you
can also check out the other products
that they offer so thank you so much
heel for sponsoring this episode this
episode is sponsored by kajabi and
they've actually got something really
valuable for all of our Deep dive
listeners now if you haven't heard of
kajabi it's basically a platform that
helps creators diversify their Revenue
with courses and membership sites and
communities and podcasts and coaching
tools so it's one of the best places for
creators and entrepreneurs to build a
sustainable business we started using
kajabi earlier this year and as soon as
we started using it we were like oh my
God why haven't we been using this
product for the last 3 years it's got
everything you'd possibly need for
running an online course or hosting an
online community or building an online
coaching business and it essentially
makes it really easy to run your entire
online business from payments to
marketing tools to analytics kajabi has
everything that we creators need all in
one place and actually you don't
necessarily need a huge audience to
generate a sustainable income a Creator
on kajabi can for example make $100,000
by converting just 350 customers a year
depending on your price points and in
fact there are creators on the platform
that are making millions of dollars
every year with fewer than 100,000
followers across the social media
platforms we've been using kajabi to
host all of our online courses since the
start of 2023 from our $1 part-time
YouTuber foundations to help people
start off on their YouTube Journey all
the way up to our $5,000 package for the
part-time YouTuber accelerator which
gives you access to me and my team and
kajabi does not take any cut of what you
earn creators keep and own everything
the way kajabi makes money is through
the monthly subscription fee and even
though we generate like literally
millions of dollars every year from
kajabi we're still only paying them a
couple hundred a year and actually in
their lifetime kajabi have paid out over
$6 billion do to creators that's billion
with a be and over a thousand creators
have become millionaires through
products on the platform now back in May
2023 I did a keynote at a kajabi in real
life kajabi Heroes Event in Austin Texas
and in that keynote I talked about the
exact steps that I used to grow my
business from0 to over $2.5 million per
year from course Revenue alone now
people paid for the pretty expensive
tickets to watch this keynote at the
kajabi hero live event but as an
exclusive deal for deep dive listeners
kajabi have very kindly offered to
provide the recording of that keynote
completely for free to anyone who
listens to this podcast so if you're
interested in getting completely free
access to that keynote just head over to
kajabi.com Ali that's kajabi.com Ali and
that'll be linked in the show notes in
the video description as well you just
enter your email address and then you
will get the recording of that keynote
completely for free whether or not you
ever become a kajabi customer so thank
you so much to kajabi for sponsoring
this episode okay so this is like I've
I've I've I've never before heard the
sort of it's it's super helpful to hear
like the history of and how this stuff
developed because I feel like stuff is
sort of slotting into place into place
in my mind we haven't even got to GPT
yet yeah I think that'll come that'll
come in a little bit so it sounds so at
the time it's like like the the
sequential decision tree is intuitive
it's like okay I can see that like in in
medicine for example I can see that you
know if ask this question you'll get one
of four responses based on one of those
four responses you can ask this question
and eventually you can imagine like a
very big decision tree and I can
intuitively imagine coding that into a
computer or whatever and it can make a
decision but then we get to this thing
where it's like feed feed this machine a
million images of a cat and the Machine
will figure out how to classify cat that
is completely unintuitive to me like
could cannot even begin to imagine how
you could solve that I can give you a
conceptual a simple way of understanding
it one of the earliest forms of machine
learning between basically 1990 and 2000
was handwriting recognition uh and so by
the year 2000 there wasn't a post office
in the world that was read or in the
western world that was reading uh uh
envelopes it was simply scanning it
through and then knowing where how to
sort them and and deliver them so let's
have if if I write a letter the the just
the alphabet A to Z yeah um and then we
wanted to identify and we put it on a a
grid yeah like graph paper and then we
wanted to write all the rules of an N
being a vertical line then a diagonal
line then another vertical line but then
there's the lower case and that little
like a like a upside down U the little
stem and all that we could Define all
the ways in which on our grid that we
have what an N looks like uppercase and
lowercase but if your handwriting is
different than my handwriting we've got
a problem right so uh we'd have to then
do it again and do it again rewrite the
rules but if we take everyone in this
postal code of London right every all
25,000 people and have them write a to
zed and we throw it into a machine and
we overlay that right now that we've
overlaid it on our grid we're going to
have these big massive blurry lines
right if you imagine because everyone's
going to be a little bit different it's
never no one's going to be exact it's
not going to be the or ar typle n but a
machine learning algorithm will see that
that's an n and not a w it's an n and
not an R sometimes an R does look like
an N depending on this the lowercase R
and the lowercase n but it's going to
make an inference and it's probably
going to do really well if you have a
million of these Suddenly It's going to
improve the accuracy and although
sometimes we'll get things wrong like
the r and the N it's going to have
learned it's going to have taught itself
how to decipher an r and an all of the
letters so you that same conceptual idea
of if you will layering everything on
top of each other and then coming up
with the traits that best predict that
as one thing versus another making just
a pro a a problem of probability a big
probability table uh that's a reframing
that's that's changing the actual
approach by which we do it it's also
incredibly humbling because it presumes
that the human being cannot explicitly
describe the phenomenon it's trying to
accurately predict there's a saying in
the social sciences that about latent
knowledge um we know more than we can
tell tell MH we know more than we can
tell which is to say that we can't
always express something but we still
have it latent latent knowledge in our
minds this is a way by which in Fact
Computers can tap into a form of latent
information latent knowledge to come up
with answers and why I want to stress
that and I'll end here is that that
humbling is pretty incredible because
you might say well if a computer can
just decipher handwriting all the better
to it saves us some time great but what
if the computer is deciphering the
probability that someone's going to have
cancer or not suddenly that Doctor Who
felt that they were very proud of their
education and their grades and their
their parents you know great well wishes
when they got their degree and all of
their years of experience they're now a
little bit knocked off their pedestal
what is their role I still think they
have a huge role to play and their
knowledge is still valuable but you
could imagine that Diagnostics in
medicine is going to go the same way and
it actually might become more not not
only might will become more accurate
than the human being because it can
decipher and it can identify different
patterns that we wouldn't even think to
consider or we don't actually physically
see or we can't mental mentally
Gro the the mathematical models though
so if we if we take this letter grid
again so what what I matching in my mind
let's let's take a 4x4 grid and if you
imagine writing the alphabet in each
one you'll get a for is is the pixel on
or off basically is it like like is
there something in the box or is it
empty and so like an a would you'd be
like so first think of think of the
graph paper do you remember how in in
when when you when you went from high
school to secondary school to college
and then to grad school the the graph
paper changed right you had these like
big boxes right it was never it wasn't a
grid it wasn't a quadrant 4x4 it was
like on a page you would imagine doing
it on a full page you've got like you
know 30 by 30 but then suddenly you had
those 30 by 30 but then you had these
like little smaller ones by 10
underneath it right so now you have like
300 by 300 let's take the three let's go
by pixel so let's do 3 million by 3
million right and let's now look at the
a now what you're looking for is an edge
you're seeing dark versus light and
you're seeing now a curve all that awful
geometry and then trigonometry that we
had to learn it's come back and that's
why AI Engineers are getting a quarter
million dollars as a starting salary and
we're not right because they actually
remember it and they actually advanced
in that so suddenly you see the the
system can is transforming it into just
numbers but can actually see that if you
will the angle of what becomes an a as
well as all of the
permutations and of how it doesn't
conform to the perfect angle but is
close enough to that to that which it
predicts now to be an a that's how it's
working and it's looking for an edge and
it it identifies it in this particular
in the rate in relation to every other
pixel on our plane yeah on our surface
and so the example of having a million
images of a cat it's basically just that
just like more sophisticated because
soup up it's more complicated when you
have other things going on and it's a
cat rather than blank and ABC exactly
okay so it was these three guys in the
80s 90s early 2000s who were like this
is they held the light they kept they
they kept the light the pilot light
burning for for using statistics which
then became called uh not just neural
networks but deep learning and they what
what's a neural network like what oh
yeah so a neur a neural network is
actually describes our brains uh the
neurons uh that fire in our brains with
synapses and how I mean the way of
thinking of it is in our minds we have
these things called synapses which are
little nerve endings and they connect to
each other and ideas are formed when
what is it um uh synopses that fire
together wire together and so um you
would when you see uh your your your
your mother um you can recognize your
mother's face in a particular region of
the brain and you recognize all the
different things and memories come
flooding back into you and you can do
that all the time and even when you're
not seeing your mother but you're
thinking of your mother within uh within
um
MRI machine we can identify the same
part of the brain uh firing okay so we
understand that these are these neurons
where memories are stored as well we
could I could I could talk for 10,000
hours about this and the fact is pretty
soon you'd realize that we know far far
far less about this than is there so
it's really an early young science right
um
the there's more mystery to the Mind
than than answers but what we still try
to do is take this as a rough model very
approximate almost like a cartoon
version and apply it to an artificial
neural network okay and what we're
trying to do is we're creating a what we
call a neuron but what it is is a
logistical regression but uh it is
taking a piece of data and it is doing a
regress on it but you would have lots of
different connections you have a lot of
data and you have you it is it might be
unstructured if you will it's not in any
particular form and what you are doing
is you are feeding it in and from one
layer of abstraction it is for example
trying to like put down a grid and look
at the contrast is it white or dark and
then at the next layer it's looking at a
little bit more detail how dark is it is
it very dark is it a little bit dark and
suddenly when you get to the middle of
it it's able to identify things that now
look like an x-ray and you can you would
be able to see that in fact it's able to
see what looks to be a femur but with a
fissure in it and is that just some sort
of problem with the lens or just some
noise in the system or is there a
fracture in it and another layer it
becomes even more clear to the system
that in fact this looks like a fracture
and it looks like other fractures you've
had before until the by the end and we
now have these with have billions and
then trillions of of sort of connections
there uh it can then make a diagnosis
based on it this is a very highlevel
conceptual way of what an artificial
neural network would do that kind of
mimics a brain not really right I think
because there's more of the brain that
we know and that this is sort of a a
plastic version of it so we have these
the this deep Learning System that when
we apply a lot of data and it's a lot of
his hand tuned there's a lot of trial
and error to see if they can get the
output that we want it sort of worked
there were these other other little
advances in the last eight years or so
of um of AI one called Transformers um
the other uh is a way in which it it
takes the information and it um uh it uh
it does something called back
propagation in which it it it takes its
answers and it it goes back in time to
recalculate everything it has we have
all of these little techniques that all
together LED to a way that we could
collect lots of text and by predict and
by doing what Google was doing starting
about a decade ago of autocomplete we
start typing a search query and it
completes what it should be we could
start doing that with first sentences
and then paragraphs and then entirely
new text and that was what GPT did it
was able to there's a lot of other
Innovations as well into it but it
became a complete GameChanger that it
could be so effective almost magical
right that when you go on to chat GPT
and then GPT 4 you can give it a prompt
and you can get a a pretty extraordinary
answer back as well and that's where we
are today and that's really in some ways
a whole new beginning what is a
Transformer like what does what does
that mean man I'm I I knew you going to
ask um I am not going to try to explain
Transformers I was thinking I could
watch a YouTube video about let me give
you a um you don't use words we use
tokens are like the roots or suffix and
and plurals of words and um try
to and then you just
read it's a process it's a process of of
recombination but it's pretty I mean I
used to I had been thinking about it
like a year ago but it's uh it is pretty
remarkable that you can bring these
tokens together and just predict ahead
to such a degree that you get um answers
that are um amazingly appropriate Let Me
Maybe the most important thing to keep
in mind when you're using GPT is what
the system is doing and what it's
not GPT is not giving you the answer
remember going back to all the history
of AI it's an inference gbt doesn't
actually know anything right there's no
answer to be had it's like you know the
the 1 2 4 FS or the handwriting
recognition which there's no archetypal
thing but it's making an inference of
what it could be what this could be gbt
is giving you what it thinks a correct
answer looks like right it's not the
thing itself it's not the answer it's a
sarum it's a reflection it's an
inference it's like it's like looking
through two stages of a mirror it's what
it thinks it predicts the right answer
resembles y right that's going to be
really important because when people say
Well it hallucinates it's not accurate
the point is like accuracy was never
part of its mental model it doesn't have
a mental model It's Not a Human Being it
doesn't have a sense of causality it
doesn't have any in haate knowledge it
doesn't have any morality so it can't
even be held accable for its problems
right it's simply a prediction it's a
coin TOS that it says I bet we're going
to toss this coin in this sequence in
this order and lo and behold it
did
so
what's it it seems like there have been
a lot of advancements recently and it
seems at least if I look on Twitter that
the pace of development in AI is
accelerating is that fair to say or is
that just uh we've been talking about
incredible it's and it's always for the
last 10 years 15 years it's been
accelerating far faster than the leading
people in the in the field thought it
would that to me is the most remarkable
thing um things that we said in the book
Big Data or the things that I gave in
talks 5 years later that I imagined was
going to be coming down the pike within
my lifetime happened within 2 years 5
years like I blinked and we had Alexa
and voice recognition right I blinked
again and we had GPT and I'm suffering
from more Whiplash than anyone else
because I was there I was present at the
creation in terms of the modern variant
of machine learning and I'm stunned by
the
progress I'd love to talk about some
dangers of AI but before we do that
let's talk about some benefits um
there's a quote from your book is which
is that as the technology evolves many
look to AI to remedy social ills that
people have shown themselves to be
unable to address what do you mean by
that so uh when we look at the world and
we realize we've got all these problems
I think a lot of people are going to
realiz people have already realized that
in fact the biggest problem is us right
we are cognitively incapable to
address what's in front of us right
whether it's climate change whether it's
um
inequalities um whether it's you know
this data duty of care of of of
transforming the world and so that we
apply information to solve our problems
so what we so the whole and Daniel Conan
and others have pointed out uh he's the
cognitive psychologist who show showed
us about our cognitive biases have
showed us all the ways in which our
decisionmaking uh is improper a
short-term bias an immediacy bias so
we'd rather you know have Jam today than
Jam tomorrow we'd rather have go on
everyone wants to go on a vacation today
and while we're heating up the Earth
that's going to make our cities explode
into firestorms tomorrow so maybe we
need an algorithm to solve that problem
instead maybe we want to hand off some
of our decision- making whether it's in
the area of public policy not just in
the area of marketing to an AI algorithm
to do better than the human project
because it looks like we're going
headlong into our
destruction I just agree with that I
think we need to apply AI in lots of
areas in society where we can make
improvements and in fact I as you as you
know I believe we have a moral duty to
apply AI in those ways I think we would
be a wise wouldn't be a wise Society if
we didn't yeah however I also think that
human beings have a mental flexibility
that AI systems never will and we also
have a sense of higher purpose and
deeper meaning and a a moral guidance
that and and individual Transcendence
and respect for the collectivity that we
can't presume an AI would and as a
result I believe that we need to get
better at being humans and tap those
deeper areas within us to see the world
in the with the right frames through the
right mental model one that respects the
Dignity of humans and the long-term
viability of our species and to uh
improve the world applying AI rather
than handing off our cognitive functions
to to AI H
okay so it's almost like just to draw
another analogy
[Music]
that people should use computers in
their day-to-day work because it's just
allows you to do way more of things and
it would be a bit weird for a government
agency to insist on not using computers
because they want to use pen and paper
to make all all the decisions it would
just be a bit bizarre like we've got
computers come on let's use it sounds
like your view of AI is that hey this is
sort of like computers to . oh we've got
all the data let's use it to inform our
decision- making or as fundamental as
electricity or as fundamental as
numeracy and the alphabet right like we
wouldn't we wouldn't like French mimes
try to mime you know you know what we
want to do to each other right we would
just use language because we have
language right well just because it's
took us several thousands of years and
we had it for we can we can imagine that
AI can will someday become as
foundational as these other as these
other tools or Technologies like
language numeracy
mathematics uh
electricity Computing and so given given
the pace of development in AI it sounds
like you don't think that it will within
the next few years develop the mental
flexibility that humans
have no I I think that's true it will
not I think AI is still going to Astound
us AI will still be will be able to do
things that human beings can't do it
already can so we should definitely
apply it and use it but we need to be uh
the controller of the AI rather than
controlled by AI we need to embrace the
AI era and we again we need to apply AI
in all the ways in which we can but we
need to make sure that we don't give up
our decisionmaking processes in this and
that we aren't simply the object of the
machine but we remain sort of subjects
in this universe and that which is
sacred in this
universe this is
the question is is this a tool or is
this an
organism uh are we giving rise have we
created a souped up hammer or light bulb
or we created a new entity a new
organism that grows and develops on its
own the answer is it's a little bit of
both right however I don't think that we
should take the Frankenstein monster
that's that's actually pejorative I
retract that I take that back it's not a
Franken sign monster at all it could be
we could make one but let's just say we
don't want to we don't want to take this
um organism that has some features of De
of
self-development right and autonomy and
to treat it with the equivalence of a
human being or of a leader of of of of
someone that's greater than who we are I
think that's just really dangerous okay
and the reason why is that we as human
beings have have a intellectual
flexibility that the AI does not have in
some ways cannot have because it's not
alive and we are alive it's in adamant
and we are adamant and by being alive I
think we participate with something
greater than ourselves that's something
that is that we don't understand but I
think that the only way to understand it
is on a spiritual level rather than a
purely rational level and it is this
fabric this weave that we share with
everyone alive with us with our
posterity and with our ancestors
um and machines don't have that and to
think that we can have this just because
we have this machine that can actually
so much more than we can on an
intellectual level doesn't mean that it
should be doing everything because we
are more than our intellect we are also
our spirit for lack of a better
term I like the conversation has gone in
this direction so I've been I've been
exploring well somewhat dabbling in the
whole spirituality stuff recent recently
as well and it's just
like I think as like I'm very much
someone who lives in the mind and uh
very much struggle to feel even like the
emotions in my body for example and so
now as I'm as I'm reading you know Sam
Harris stuff but also other other things
around spirituality that there seems to
be this plane of existence that is just
like impossible to put into words the
thing that we call the spirit or the
soul or any of this kind of stuff sounds
like you're a strong proponent of that
that view as well completely U not
because I particularly ascribe to one
religion or another but because it from
I because but because it's right in
front of me I mean I see it everywhere I
look uh William Blake famously wrote you
know all that is living is sacred and
you think well yeah no duh of course
like isn't it like who would make the
case that it isn't but then you look a
little bit deeper and you realize holy
there's a lot of people who are so
wrapped up in their rationality and
their scientism and their and their
logical thinking that they and their
quest for Rock Solid empirical evidence
that which is you know seeing is
believing that which I can touch is all
that exists who fail to see that which
is invisible um and I I use the term
only in the the
santuari uh way uh an Anan s was the
person who
wrote and he wrote
um that which is invisible that which is
essential is invisible to the
eyes and of course he's talking about
there is so that emotional connection to
things but it could also apply to that
which again we've got terrible language
for it we'll call the spiritual uh it
seems to have these sort of Echoes of um
of religion and it need not right
because it the the ancient Greeks had
the idea of several ways of interacting
with the world and thinking about the
world and one was logos and the other
one was Mythos and logos was obviously
logical thinking and Mythos was tapping
you know deeper meaning of not myth in
terms of that which is uh false but
Mythos as in that which we can perceive
but is beyond our rational approach of
senses and between the two forms of
Truth the reeks F thought that Mythos
was the more true and that logos was
simply a tool after all you know any
lawyer in a courtroom can apply logos to
win his case but does that necessarily
lead us closer to truth that's debatable
so I think that post Enlightenment now
it's getting very gr Grand I accept but
post Enlightenment we have deferred most
of our acceptance of thinking and our
conceptions of the universe to the logos
at the expense of the Mythos and of
course that's what William Blake was
railing against and so many other people
we've bastardized the term imagination
as something that is almost like like
fantasy when in fact imagination is
really about is is is pure cernus and is
pure Pythagoras it's about seeing that
which exists within our Mind's Eye not
with our physical eyes why this matter
so much for us right now is look at AI
look at its decisions it's all logos no
Mythos CS Lewis the famous uh you know
writer and and philosopher and and
Christian the Ian in some ways um
identified in one of his articles men
without chests and what he meant by Men
Without chests is that the people
who are living with their their
appetites and their stomach are living
with their uh their minds and their
intellect but are missing that which is
in their chest their Spirit their idea
of of of transcendence their idea of
selfhood their idea of of the of a soul
again terrible term because it has those
connotations of religion but it need not
one can be secular but see a form of I
don't want to say Divinity within
ourselves but um but a a special
Celestial fire a a a something special
that exists that I think in our our most
quietest moments we see as true and in
fact in those special moments we
recognize that the reality is those
moments of
quiet Solitude and
Transcendence and that what is actually
artificial is the
daytoday leading Our Lives bus passings
and F you plumes of smoke you know
hitting our nostrils
yeah this season is Once Again being
sponsored very kindly by trading 212 now
people ask me all the time for
investment advice uh because they see
that I've made money and I've made
videos talking about where I'm investing
that money the thing that Warren Buffett
and basically everyone who's sensible in
the space recommends which is to invest
in Broad stock market index funds which
you can do completely for free using
trading 212 trading 212 is a fantastic
app that lets you invest in stocks and
shares and funds in a commission-free
fashion and they've got a bunch of
features which are really helpful which
is why I personally use trading 212 to
manage a portion of my portfolio so
firstly they've got this great pies and
auto invest feature so if you're
interested in potentially getting into
investing what you can do is you can
browse the different pies that different
people have created on the platform so
you might get like a hedge font Trader
who's gone onto the platform and has
created a pie of Investments having done
a bunch of research and stuff and that P
might be like I don't know 20% Apple 20%
Tesla 10% this 10% that but it generally
way more complicated than that and you
can see the performance of that
particular pie of stocks and shares and
funds and then if you want to copy that
pie into your own account you can just
copy and paste it directly in and then
you can invest any amount of money and
it will automatically split it according
to the allocation in the P so if you
wanted to just play around with £100 and
you were like okay that P looks good it
will split out that1 based on the
allocations of the P which is pretty
sick they've also recently added support
for multicurrency accounts now this is
really helpful because for example if
you invest in the S&P 500 which is a
us-based Index Fund then you won't get
hit with all the various foreign
exchange fees if for example you're
investing from the UK like I do and if
you have an invest or an Isa account
then trading 212 also gives you daily
interest on your uninvested cash in
pounds or Euros or us so if any of that
sounds up your straight then do please
hit the link in the video description or
in the show notes and that will let you
sign up to trading 212 and if you use
that link you will also get a completely
free share up to the value of100 so it's
literally free money so you might as
well so thank you so much trading 212
for sponsor ing this
episode um we've got a bunch of
questions from our podcast Community
around um risks to that AI has so
firstly to what extent do you think AI
could spell the end of the world like to
what extent is there an existential risk
or existential threat from AI it's
nonzero and the more that uh but the
more that we talk about it the the less
likely it becomes and the reason why is
that it like the idea that we're going
to you know hand over our launch missile
codes to an AI and then go to the beach
only to find out that there's a mushroom
cloud on the horizon is pretty remote on
the other hand in very um very miniature
ways we need to be vigilant so we
wouldn't want to handoff um if we have a
trading system at a bank um we wouldn't
want to hand it off all to an AI without
a human somehow in the loop particularly
maybe as a as a control switch so if
things start running a muck we can have
someone look at it and realize things
are indeed a muck and they can slow it
down and control it like wise in the
area of military defense uh it would it
would be actually completely heinous for
us to have systems that are autonomous
lethal systems except possibly in well
first in defense potentially and also in
in ways that are very um are are very
circumscribed but I think you still
would want human beings somehow in the
loop Reaction Time becomes a problem uh
because you know Wars will be fought and
or combat will be fought at a right at
at a a quicker Pace but I still think we
probably both sides have an interest in
slowing it down and therefore we need AI
Arms Control to make sure it does get
slowed down in the same way that every
country in the world can sort of use gas
weapons against any other and no one
does because they realize that there
first conventions to prevent it because
they realize just how heinous that would
be and so I think we need um I'm a
kissing jurrian in that sense Henry
chrisinger wrote a book about this and
with some co-authors and I ascribe to
that which is to say that we need to
research these weapons because we can't
give up this ability to an adversary
however we need to immediately engage in
AI arms control so that we have some
form of
um a playing field in which we have some
degree of confidence of how people will
respond to circumstances and what we
think we shouldn't pursue uh for the
sake of our common Humanity yeah and I
guess there are reasons to be optimistic
here like to your point about like gas
weapons that anyone could use them but
they don't uh because that's like
Crossing some sort of invisible line or
rather most people don't because it's
Crossing some sort of invisible line but
the so we can be a little bit uh
grateful for that but we can also be a
little bit more terrified still and the
reason why is that the the wise men and
women mostly men who who signed the
Geneva conventions uh were ones who
could look to their left and right and
see their kids that they went to high
school with secondary school with
blinded by chemical weapons or not even
there and dead and they know they're
grieving mothers they had they
understood something about the world
that we in our CED rather pathetic
ticktan lives have forgotten or never
knew or don't know or in people who
don't care particularly for younger
people you can look to Elders who just
no longer care and who no longer see it
never were part of it never part of
their narrative and if you don't
actually have it in your DNA in your
epigenetics you don't feel it that it's
not coursing through your bloodstream
the absolute abject horror of either war
or intolerance or the absence of Freedom
yeah or the the denigration of human
dignity if you don't have that in your
body you don't know it and if
you don't know it you're not going to
make decisions based on it and I see it
every day I can't look at Contemporary
American Poli without realizing how the
hell did that happen right and the
reason why is that if you're if you're
if you come from a different narrative
one of fleeing oppression one of being
of of incredible uh fright of of
annihilation you see the world
differently and you uh you're a little
bit more Vigilant uh and you're a little
bit more ready to find mechanisms what
the definition of laws the wise
constraints that set men free to find
the way of having the rule of law to
ensure human dignity everyone's
[Music]
dignity why is this so you mentioned the
tikto and stuff like what is it about
modern society that makes us in your
view less good at this than for example
our our grandparents were when they
signed the Geneva Convention yeah first
great grandparents but um the uh so I
don't want to sound like an old old fogy
that would be rather pathetic and also
probably not who I am but I would I
think that there's first been definitely
a lack of sacrifice on Modern
Generations this is going back about 50
years right since post Vietnam was the
last time that a generation had to
really
confront be you know being a a pawn or
an object in this world and not a
subject in this world having someone
else push one in an environment where
they didn't want to go to serve someone
else's aims so that's been a long time
so we we're in a world in which we
there's been an
infantilization of a lot of Our Lives
secondly we've got these Creature
Comforts that we never had before we're
no longer dying of of of of a of a
blister or or of a scratched Thorn from
a rose which was actually very common
place only 100 years ago literally 100
years ago um in the book framers uh that
I wrote after big data we begin the book
by talking about how the president of
the United States's um son got a blister
playing tennis on the White House Lawns
and perished you know died of of of
septus within a week right that his
wealth and Status couldn't save him no
penicillin and then thirdly our
attention span has definitely decreased
uh and as a result we are no longer
holding on to substantial ideas again
this isn't old fism you know there's a
lot of social science Jonathan height
among others have pointed out these
pathologies uh and a lot of the problems
have emerged actually since the Advent
of social media every kid knows this
we're all a basket case of depression
and anxiety because we're so well
connected in a way that we hadn't been
in the past so people are talking about
a digital detox um these are new tools
and we need new social practices around
them um just like um in Asia between
1950 and the year 2000 it went from a
famine and undernourishment to obesity
being the healthcare crisis we have the
same problem with our digital tools
after 25 years of the internet so to
speak in the web um rough hand um to say
well how do we best bring this into our
society there's the famous cliche of of
American Diplomat asking the Chinese
what do you think of the French
Revolution and the Chinese saying it's
uh this in the 1980s or 1970s and uh the
Chinese uh leader replying it's too soon
to tell this 200 years later what do you
think of the financial French Revolution
is too soon to tell it turns out it's a
it's a it's apocal it's a mistranslation
but it's a joke sh the joke at the time
was the Chinese thought in such a
long-term mindset that something that
happened only 200 years ago is too soon
to tell and this there's also a NIC
little aphorism that in Britain you know
that for in British institutions the
first 500 years is always the toughest
right that long-term thinking that we
need to have the tools that we're using
like social media are only 25 10 years
old 25 years old and we need to come up
with right practices in general I think
that we are a very cited generation that
has that in which life and politics and
social relations resembles more a video
game than actually something that's real
and as a result you can have flame Wars
without thinking the of what the
consequences are um you have and
trolling without actually realizing
these are actually human people human
beings and again we've lost the sense of
um tolerance equality and human
dignity human digity as in well I yeah I
stress that because I've been thinking
about the French revolution's great
aphorism of um Liberty equality and
solidarity and I've been thinking about
the the the concept of equality and
human freedom and I think that there's
both of them are I've not written about
this yet I'm still sort of working it
out of my
mind freedom and liberty isn't quite
right because we're not free I mean
we're we're or we're not we're not equal
in the sense that we're all born very
differently right we don't have equality
so people want to use the term Equity
what does that mean and then Freedom
sometimes we have too much Freedom right
in fact the the whole point about
civilization is we curtail our freedom
right we can't live together unless we
curtail our freedom John Stewart Mill
famously is telling me that my my
freedom to extend my arm ends at the
beginning of your nose right you you
exactly this idea is no harm so I so I
wonder if maybe we need to introduce a
new
concept uh it's an old concept too but
of dignity of an inherent dignity that
we treat with each other and that my
right to be treated with dignity uh is
predicated on my treating you with
dignity and vice versa and that means
that people like Steve banon and Donald
Trump can't do X and Y to me right
because I am owed by by Dent of being a
living being yeah I'll first say a human
being I'm owed a for of dignity then if
we extend it to a living being ow a form
of dignity maybe we don't then have
these Factory chickens and and things
and then eventually do we have to get
rid of farms because we can't have temp
Tomatoes I think that'd be going too far
but I do think that I'm captivated on
the idea of if 150 years ago there was
slavery and intellectual justifications
of slavery and the rule of law that
enshrined slavery and today that seem
bat crazy what is it that in
hundred years people are going to look
back at my generation and things that I
do and say how the hell could you have
done that like what what were you
thinking so one example is like like why
would I buy a plastic water bottle like
would I really buy water in plastic like
maybe that is maybe that's actually
heinous and I'm not realizing it but I
think there's a lot of other things and
the area of dignity I think for me might
be that sort of ground truth concept
that if we accept that we all have that
we then can find we can rebuild our
society in a way in a form that's just
and honorable to
everyone it's quite an old-fashioned
concept or seemingly oldfashioned
concept the idea of dignity um remember
a couple years ago I read I think it was
the Righteous Mind by Jonathan height
and how you I think in that book he
poses that scenario of like you know is
it morally wrong to have sex with a dead
chicken it's very hard to make a case
for that with in the the liberal
morality worldview where it's just about
you know harm and consent and stuff it's
like you know the thing's dead you're
going to eat it anyway it's like I guess
what's the harm but the way you do
explain that as being
morally perhaps morally wrong is through
the idea of sanctity and dignity and
these words that
seem seem old so oldfashioned that it
seems unfashionable to use them as a way
of saying like oh Donald Trump's behav
was undignified and therefore it was
wrong kind of thing I wouldn't go I
wouldn't I don't the undignified thing I
don't have much time for I think that
that might have been it was undignified
but so what like I mean okay it's I
mean the the I don't regard dignity like
that it's more of a deep respect for for
the human being and for the the
sacredness that they have okay right um
the sanctity of a human life and living
things yeah I'll give you I'll give you
another example of this which is um if
you look at the AI all the AI papers
that are coming out uh in the last few
years they have typically about between
eight and about 30 co-authors but if I
love looking at the names of the
co-authors because you have this
hodgepodge of the entire world there's
going to be a guy like in the most
recent paper on Consciousness that came
out uh we're recording in in uh late
August 2023 there's uh big paper on on
AI and Consciousness and there's one guy
like Peter West but there's all of these
other names that um which and I like
that because it's a very it's a very
Christian name right in Western you know
Anglo-Saxon name but then there's all
these other names that you some you can
say oh that's Chinese or that one's
Indian but or subcontinent but you just
really have no idea where it comes from
you think whoa like what's that about um
with just cues and lots of consonants
and so what I love about this is like it
seems to me an absolute abute affront to
racists who somehow like how you can
have any sort of foundation of racism as
in a person has a different skin color
like literally their gradation of
melatonin differs and
therefore there's something out like
you're going to treat them with less
respect or you're going to think less of
them or they're ipof facto less
intelligent like it's from an
intellectual standpoint it's ridiculous
racism is a little bit like slavery it's
a little bit like um all these other
weird things that we no longer do but
were done thousands of years ago right
can't think anything worse than owning
another human being so it seems to me so
fantastically peculiar that we would
have people who would still have as a
mental model something that just seems
so ridiculous and it's nice to see in an
AI paper that the racists are on the
lower end of achievement in the world
right maybe there's causality there
while You've Got This Global hodg podge
of of individuals who are at the most
exceptional level transforming the world
in terms of this concept of progress and
fulfillment and betterment so it's so
it's a it's a lovely thing so the
dignity that I'm referring to is this
dignity that adheres to every individual
qua individual by Dent of being a person
in this world I mean it's such a cliche
but it's worth repeating that like you
have 8 billion people in the world each
one is different and individual the way
I think about it is that it's like
traffic you're not in traffic you are
traffic and likewise we're not in the
world we are the world all of us all of
us together right and we're all
interacting with each other it's almost
like atoms or electrons bouncing across
each other creating the world that we
have and hence the the second book uh
frame is all about mental models and the
power of mental models and the limits of
AI because we're all in this together
and we need to respect each other's
mental models and ways of thinking in
order to solve our problems nice um we
had a bunch of questions from our
telegram Community around people worried
or asking about to what extent AI runs
the risk of quote taking people's jobs I
wonder what's your what's your take on
absolutely it's going to take our jobs
yeah totally uh not everyone's job
there'll always be I think there's
always going to be work to do whether
that's well-paid work whether that's
satisfying work is up to us to create
but again we're agents we have agency
we're not we're subjects in the world
not objects in the world if we think
that we're going to Simply Be victims uh
of the we're the pinball in the pinball
machine of AI and we're just going to be
bouncing around from things then that's
what's going to happen to us but if not
we can recognize that we have agency we
can direct this in the ways that we want
to direct it and up enshrine human
values in this case dignity in ways that
we think we need to have it work is
definitely going to change everyone's
work is going to change but that's
happened with electricity that happened
with computers that happened with you
know obviously with with the slide rule
um and so we need to reimagine and I
think it's going to be taing our our
imagination uh reimagine what will bring
value to the world and then do
that I subjects rather than objects I
guess you know the classic example is OB
but what about the truck drivers the
truck drivers jobs are going to be
replaced with a with like
autonomous trucks and stuff like that
every time sometimes but um I I think
you might still want someone in the cab
I mean if the truck driver can sleep
during the those long stretches across
Nevada and and the dtas um all power to
them right they can be in the cab
sleeping and doing things you know
playing a video game interacting with
their children and wife by by Zoom um
sure that sounds great but then we might
need them at for edge cases when they
for the last mile people are saying that
that's a likely place we'll need them we
might want them to Simply have the
transactions when they arrive where
they're going so there can be a human to
human you know legal receipt of goods
eventually that might go away and it's
all going to be automated but it might
not in the relevant time frame but
there's very few people in the world who
who aspired when they were young and 5
years old say I want to be a truck
driver you know alone in my cab going
through dtas on adderal and Coke and you
know uh and and coffee trying to stay
awake and not crash my cab and getting
somewhere with a dispatcher breathing
down my neck saying I'm running late and
watching the fuel right like nobody says
that's the life I wanted right so why VA
the truck driver I think in in the short
term I don't think in the short term
it's the jobs are going to go away
immediately and I think there will be a
transition and that has always been the
case sometimes those transitions have
been in the history of Technology have
been very violent and very difficult the
Looms and the the L
Ned L but I think that we've learned
from that that we're going to try to
shape this technology around human needs
and human Ambitions and even the 5-day
Work Week is an artifact of modernity
because 150 years ago was a Six-Day work
week right and the five-day work week
was a reform of industrialization so
that we could have two days of leisure
not just one and the trend these days is
to actually consider the idea of a 4-day
work week which I think is the direction
things are headed in yeah we've got a
nday fortnite in our team so every other
Friday is a day off which people seem to
like yeah exactly um final thing I
wanted to ask you about so you talk um a
lot in the book around the human
advantage over AI so like top level and
people gas can can read the book to find
out more but like what is the human
advantage over AI what are the things
that humans can what what do you what do
you feel are the things that humans can
uniquely do that AI can't SL won't be
able to do for at least a while there's
three things in particular the first is
cause ity the second is counterfactuals
and the third is constraints causality
is this idea of cause and effect this
inherent and innate ability to
understand cause and effect machines can
do that Based on data but humans can do
that more than just data we have a sort
of instinctual ability to see that and
also more importantly we're primed to
see cause and effect in fact we're so
good at it we see cause and effect where
it doesn't really exist we're constantly
mistaking causality and getting it wrong
but it makes the world a predictable
place and a repeatable place machines
have to be trained in causality it
doesn't come natural to them the second
is
counterfactuals we fill in the blanks we
see what isn't there literally will you
have never had the experience of a hot
furnace pouring molten metal on top of
you but you don't need to have that you
know to avoid when the lava comes
pouring gushing out of the out of the
steel mill you run for your life because
you know what's going to happen and what
you've done is played The Game of Life
two ticks ahead by filling in
information that you don't have based on
information that you do and that is the
sense of counterfactual reasoning it's a
magical
orchestrational uh form of cognition
that machines don't have other animals
don't have but we do have right and then
thirdly we've got constraints it's not
enough to Simply live in a world in
which anything is possible particularly
imagination we can render anything
fantastically in our minds but in fact
that we constrain it in certain and wise
ways to the to the most appropri
mechanism to get done what we need at a
given time so that we can act in time
these three features of cognition
causality counterfactuals constraints
are the three sort of building blocks of
our mental models of our frames of the
way in which we see the world one way
versus another and if we apply our
mental models which machines can't do
and we adjust them and we reframe
situations based on the here and now and
the requirements of the given time that
might be different than an earlier time
we can actually solve our
problems okay nice that's good stuff um
one sort of unrelated thing I wanted to
ask you about what's it like working at
The Economist it's like i' I've I've
I've got the I've got the app I read it
occasionally I sort of always aspire to
read more of it because I'm like oh I I
want to be more informed about the world
and then like life gets in the way and
like ah screw being informed about the
world but what I saw that you were uh
like a a deputy editor is it at the like
what does what does that mean and like
what what is the organization like what
do it yeah that's lot of questions there
we've got a whole another podcast um so
the acoms is a lovely place um I had
worked at a place called The
International H Tribune in the 90s I
then worked at the Wall Street Journal
around 2000 2001 2002 and in Hong Kong
and I uh and I I really felt that after
911 that I just couldn't be a journalist
anymore I just I didn't like journalism
I thought it was I thought the media was
cheap it was simple it was simplistic it
was always a similar chrum of reality
not the real thing fake new everything
was fake news there's an element to it
because of course you're simply
representing what's what the issue is
you can't tell the whole story in the
because of deadline time and also
because of the size constraint and also
because you don't know all of it at at
any given time it's just hard to do and
so I uh had a fellowship at American
University and really was sort of
defining myself as not being a
journalist anymore and I realized I if I
was to write if I was to work anywhere
I'd work at the one place that I didn't
think was journalism but something
different something apart and that was
The Economist which is to say it it's it
had a mission that was different it was
first trying it was it was thoughtful it
was um patient it was very um balanced
uh it was very partial as well it had
its values and it really pushed forward
for its values so it didn't have this
false impartiality uh that I saw
particularly in the American Media that
was trying to be so even-handed that it
also it often didn't get to the actual
truth of the subject and so uh luckily
after writing a few pieces for them uh
they brought me on to the staff and uh I
started writing for them I then became
an editor for them and now as the deputy
executive editor I look at all of the
ways in which we're applying our brand
to our different business activities to
see that aderes to our values and we can
sort of raise our game in all the ways
in which a modern Media company uh goes
to Market whether it's not just our
journalism but it's more importantly or
as importantly our events are we have
Economist education in which we have a
great Education team that's offering
courses to people we have a research arm
and do that does extraordinary work
there and it all needs to somehow be
unified and and an organization needs
one person to both be the lion tamer
cracking the whip as well as the great
Champion for these other business units
and that's my job H how how big is the
organization like how many people so at
the newspaper there's probably about now
I'd say three about 2 150 people in
editorial and that is depends on how you
count it but it's as reporters and
editors as well as the social media team
as well as the film team and the
podcasting team as well as the
production people as well as the
graphics Department the data journalism
the photo department Etc and
illustrators so that's at the widest
level but we also have a commercial side
that will do advertising and and other
things but at The Economist group we've
got about 1,600 people because we've got
an events team and we've got the
educational team we've got the research
arm and the research arm does things
like healthcare data among other things
and so it's a it we've grown I've been
there for 20 years to become basically
from a weekly newspaper to magazine
calling s newspaper to a diversified
media conglomerate and that's been
glorious it's hard to do and not many
people have been able to maintain it
it's also hard to maintain because you
need to be very because the world's a
complicated place and you need to make
sure that you're how you're interacting
with it is in the right way have you
seen in the last 20 years that you know
the the the sort of Topline thing that
often people say is that oh you
know journalism is dying because people
are reading things less and the Tik the
tiktock ification of the world means
that no one wants to read a long form
magazine anymore have you have you seen
that or is it like how how are you guys
thinking about
that so we're in a world in which
multiple things can be true at the same
time right remember even in the Dark
Ages you had monasteries you had monks
and scribes right in fact you had a
flourishing of the Sciences in the 1500s
and 1600s the very time when you also
had barbarians like lopping off people's
you know limbs for fun so I think we're
reverting to a similar era in which
sadly the world is bifurcating into
those who into into into those who are
going to lead their lives without much
of a deeper care of how the world is
unfolding other than to complain about
it and be a victim of it while at the
same time there's going to be this layer
of society that understands that they
are agents and that they can uh they're
stewards and they have agency is how I
should say it that they are blessed with
the with the
resources both you know monetary and
cognitively and the
responsibilities uh in their
professional lives that they can change
the world and that that this is their
moment to do so and they need to be
armed with both information as well as a
community to make those changes and
that's what we're there for I don't
think we as an institution have thought
about it that way because we're not very
introspective we just get on with our
work and and and just and and and just
just do the best we can but again if
there's one guy there who can step back
and see it from I think there's several
people who step back and look at it at a
deeper level I'm one of those people who
are thinking about it who's realizing
that even as media the economic model of
media is collapsing even as there's a a
a societal shift towards less attention
span and do and reading less and
thinking less about ideas that there is
going to be what Arnold Toby the
historian British historian called the
creative minority he described it as
those people in every era who step
forward to save civilization if it is to
be saved at all and we are in a similar
situation right now again ever thus
we've always been in that situation but
we're again pressed with it now it's
life or Stakes death Stakes uh life or
death
Stakes that we need to um have that
Community think deep and hard about the
issues that we're facing the problems
that we have and solu and new solutions
to those problems climate change being
one of them inequality being a second
rise of AI and how we control it being a
third of a of and chemical weapons
tensions in the indopacific you name it
there's no shortage of problems that we
have uh and we need all hands on the
tiller and the most maybe most
importantly the environment that were in
the rise of national populism and the
lack of Tolerance and and respect of
human dignity bring it all together and
we need people of good values to think
through our problems and apply rational
thought to solve those problems that's
what we're there for nice um okay this
is also a somewhat random question but
you I think are the best person to
answer this um I would like to become
more uh well read about like the world
and stuff and one thing that has really
struck me in our conversation you're
like pulling out references from like
the like all of history and I'm just
like whoa like like it's it's just
incredible how like you know I'm from a
science background and now I do this
productivity stuff so I'm very familiar
with with like science is and like
medicine in the world of like self-help
but when it comes to anything resembling
the social sciences or like history or
like geography even understanding like
where certain countries are I'm like is
that country in South America or is it
like in Middle East somewhere it's like
I'm I feel so ignorant when it comes to
things outside of my my area areas of
expertise and I've always had this thing
over the last like since since like
medical school where I was like I I
really want to read The Economist I want
to be able to read The Economist and
understand what's going on in the world
and I and I'll read the sort of this
this week in brief or whatever it is for
a few weeks in a row and I just become
overwhelmed because there like there's
too much going on it's like I'm
having to Google every other word to be
like where is that country who is that
person and then you guys released the
espresso app a few years ago I was like
oh great and even then it's just like
there's a lot there that seems to
require a lot of background to really
understand to really to really
understand it so I guess my question for
you is as a Noob To The World of social
sciences and like current affairs and
politics and history and things like
that what would be a good like starting
point like starter guide to
understanding the world I am so glad uh
you asked that because I think I think
that there is a way so first and the
most important thing is that no one
should should Despair and feel depressed
and think that because
they don't feel that they have what it
takes to sort of think through a lot of
these issues that that it's just it's
futile and they should just they get
paralyzed with their unease um everyone
has to start from somewhere and although
and it's never too early or too late you
know to do so the second thing is that
these baby steps add up pretty quickly
and eventually you're in a different
place and that was my own narrative
academically and sort of thinking about
the world uh and I and so I can speak
with the authority of both failure and
success to say that look you know if
even a clown like me can make good um
anyone can anyone can so um what I would
uh I think and the second reason why I'm
so excited by the question is because I
think there is a simple answer at The
Economist we have a podcast a daily
podcast called the intelligence it's not
the intelligence like we're SN elius
it's the intelligence like an
intelligence briefing like intelligence
Services which is sort of um 30 minutes
of um three different little stories one
larger one and then two all subsidiary
ones that will give you a general
panoply of what's going on in the world
in a very accessible way because it's
it's we're interviewing our own
correspondents and the journalism that
they're producing that gives you sort of
a in miniature sort of all you need to
know to understand the world and because
a Daily Show you're almost getting an
audio version of the best that's in the
magazine so if you just were to do one
thing and that is listen to the
intelligence every day I think for the
moment it is free I think it's going
behind a pay wall at a very inexpensive
price by the way uh starting in the
Autumn but still I think it'd be worth
it because the whole idea was in fact
with our podcasting strategy is to take
a lot of our material that we were
giving away for free to create a scaled
back version of The Economist for those
people for whom it fit their lifestyle
there's lots of people who want the
weekend read who want to you can listen
to every single story that we publish
because we have professional
broadcasters reading it out on our app
so if I know lots of people who quote
unquote read entire Economist just by
exercising 3 days from Monday to from
Thursday to to to Sunday night and on
the treadmill they're listening to the
whole weekly edition of The Economist
they have the paper version never pick
it up kids get it however the the the
intelligence as a podcast is probably
the right thing for people to listen to
after one month if you're still
listening to it great you're doing great
and if you're not we're not right for
you that's fine too nice all right I
mean that sounds like a very reasonable
thing I can integrate into my life so
I'll I'll try out and I'll I'll email
you and let you know how it goes please
do good good stuff Ken thank you so much
um so we've been recording for almost 2
hours um any final pieces of advice or
words of wisdom for anyone who's who's
gotten to the end of our end of our
conversation oh my goodness um
absolutely not I mean the whole idea is
that um people who have final pieces of
advice and words of wisdom they're
always concocting something on the Fly
it's usually pretty meaningless and
we're
all scrambling in this world trying to
make sense of it um no no body has the
answers and so um maybe that's the thing
to listen the final words of of
reminding of once of myself that might
be useful to others is to know that um I
don't know what's going on I still but I
still have to make the best of it nice a
great place to end this thank you so
much thank you all right so that's it
for this week's episode of Deep dive
thank you so much for watching or
listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
going to be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then Doe
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye-bye